it's time for our pet of the week
segment Mary from fuppy is joining us
this morning and look at this cute
little guy you've got who's this is Max
oh he is five years old
he was a fluffy puppy a few years back
and then his mama got sick so she asked
us if we could find him a new home oh so
he's been in one home recently that you
know of yes
I know he's so interested in everything
that's going on but he is just the
sweetest little key and it's so soft and
cuddly yeah he loves to play ball he
just he will play ball for days he likes
to go on walks he loves to ride in the
car oh what's that so he's the perfect
companion dog absolutely it has to do
with other dogs do you know he's good
with other dogs okay great um if they're
older and they don't want to play they
might get a little irritated with him
got it but if they want to play then
he's ready come on it still has that
puppy mentality yes oh yes you do and
he's so sweet and soft so Mary now folks
want to adopt him he's available right
now yes and how would they do that
they're going to call her email they can
call or email or go on to our website
and fill out an application okay and uh
and now you guys do have some adoption
adoption events coming up yes on
Saturday
basically every Saturday we're at the
PetSmart at Charleston and Hualapai got
it and the PetSmart at North Durango and
the 215. okay so Hill Max will be at one
of those locations if he's not adopted
before then all right Mary thank you so
much Max is so busy down there sniffing
everything oh come on
camera One More Time come on there we go
we finally got his attention if you are
interested in adopting Max you can call
or email puppy that information is on
your screen